[Musique]
grâce à certaines sources nous savons
aujourd'hui que les états unis conduit
une opération top secrète
ici dans le désert qui se trouve
derrière moi est loin d'être terminée
qu'est ce qu'il veut il a fabriqué un
très grand nombre de bombes sales
si on remporte pas la victoire aura fait
tout ça pour rien je demande qu'on
envoie des drones predator dans la zone
si jamais les choses devaient tourner au
vinaigre
on leur enverra un missile hellfire vous
y allez vous le trouvez vous les lignes
on entrera par la grand'porte égard
ils sont trop nombreux couvre mois
je vous assure nous allons reprendre nos
terres
j'ai les banques officiel
pour dégager cible localiser
vous avez mon feu vert quand
à l'être
dégâts
bienvenue à tous au lycée français
albert camus
vous êtes extrêmement chanceux car vous
allez étudier dans un cadre exceptionnel
vous bénéficierez des dernières méthodes
d'enseignement encadré dans la plus
grande sécurité
toute l'équipe enseignante et moi même
avons hâte de commencer cette année et
je vous promets qu'on se rende ici vous
serez des personnes très différentes de
celles que vous êtes aujourd'hui on veut
bien nous voir
mais pas nous écouter nous sommes le
footing
c'est notre pari je sais que vous êtes
spéciale
[Musique]
dis moi quel est le plan conserver ce
soir
le monde doit savoir ce qui se passe
cousteau tu m'as m'ont ri je vois jamais
et quand je vois tout ce qui m'arrive je
pèse un milliard d'euros au fil des
ajouts près de 9000 personnes et je suis
dans la main d'un fou mon [ __ ] de
cousins ce malade ne supporte pas que
très vite on les morts il faut juste de
signer l'un dans la petite case
qu'est-ce qu'il veut exactement il va
m'aider a largement devant alors elles
chutent au chauffage pas ton cousin là
ils étaient en tout temps à bagnols la
maison partout il faut être honnête on
comprend
les autres je m'en fous du même petit 6
depuis qu'il est là tous cas ça de le
vivre s'en sort les actions les autres
copains
marre des conneries mardi dingue votre
cousin peut changer d'humeur d'une
seconde à l'autre
[Musique]
c'est plus par leurs 24 heures à toute
son équipe qu'à toi en 35 ans n'était
pas comme ça
des raisons peu ce qu'on leur montre
qu'on les aime kato toi toi tes actions
de l'apéritif à la con là
oui à des cailloux viennent
ça bouge ça saigne faux sacs roula
oh
qu'est ce qui se passe on vient d'entrer
en collision avec un vol d'oiseaux nage
je le savais
[Musique]
omar oui quand tu veux on est prêts
m'arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m libert vous êtes une des figures
incontestées de la communauté française
en séries si fabienne keller et ils
passent à une vitesse ces journées vous
êtes connus comme les pousses de
l'illustre henri maubert à l'oma du bas
nous on forme une communauté on est
soudé et si vous avez quelque chose on
sera parlerait on rentrait la reine vous
êtes encore pour deux ans à vienne
mais c'est formidable très concrets
comme la loi comment fait-on pour gérer
ton bonheur on arrive à garder les pieds
sur terre
vous avez l'ol passé henri iii qu'il ya
les vents les enfants
[Musique]
encore debout bah oui comme tu vois je
prépare fonction qu'elle paraît pas très
précis
tu te sens très loin de moi
fait des trucs chacun de notre côté
je te crois toi
c'est sûr qu'elle se doute pas d'un truc
ta femme
tous les parents d'élèves ont reçu un
mail de la maîtresse de malo qui nous
était pas du tout destiné
ça veut dire qu'elle entretient une
liaison avec un papa de l'école qui sera
l'heureux élu
tu sais malo jamais on se séparera avec
cooper
sans doute ce plan non non pas du tout
[Musique]
c'est intéressant fait le prestige les
apparences
wade
[Musique]
sarkozy
vaincus peuvent construit
on est quand même ce qu'est venu
santé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
oh
m
bienvenue à les maîtriser
c'est mon gars
[Musique]
sous
m
maman ma vie
pas mal non
l'intérim a noté
[Musique]
non
je suis ta mok book
[Musique]
vieux krust yokas 20 which is on a une
journaliste du monde
sans commentaire
camus
samedi bal
[Musique]
des étudiants réaliser un film on m'a
dit que ce film était terrifiant plus de
la moitié des gens présents se sont
enfuis de la salle de cinéma quelqu'un a
eu une crise cardiaque et il en est mort
c'est quoi le titre
parmi
je la fais de ma ville finance il te
plait mon film
qui te fait peur
[Musique]
combien de temps les suivre ses
consignes à moissy sénart moissy les
enfants vous en avez pas
[Musique]
kalilou
vous n'êtes pas françaises espagnoles
ouais ah ouais vous et que je prenais
espagnol yo melia maujean news bonjour
le louis est là
c'est qu'elle nous votre
encore ce qu'est le football à se voiler
sa sous direction
non non vous savez où j'habite
[Applaudissements]
histoire
c'est la qualité du suivi du malade j
je ne sais pas
les nominés
[Musique]
tiens ça ça fait long